[музика]
вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа я
Лара балола раді що ви приєдналися до
нас Туреччина готується до проведення
парламентських і президентських виборів
але багато Турків досі оговтуються від
наслідків руйнівних землетрусів що
сталися в районі у лютому
щонайменше 50 тисяч людей загинули майже
десяток великих міст Туреччини
перетворилися на руїни мільйони людей
втратили своїх домівки і досі потребують
допомоги
часто гори тих хто вижив змішується з
гнівом і розчаруванням багато людей
відчувають що держава і президент
ердоган їх підвели
екстрена допомога яку чиновники обіцяли
надати надходить дуже повільно а дія ман
важливий регіон для правлячої партії
президента
ердоганна пср це місто особливо сильно
постраждало від землетрусу тепер після
десятиліть його правління ця катастрофа
може коштувати йому та його партії
вирішальний голосів на виборах
кладовища водія маністає більшим з
кожним днем
після лютневих землетрусів з'явилося
понад 7 тисяч нових могил
Багато з них тимчасові без надгробків
спогади врятовані з руїн
фата нареченої
футбольне Джерсі
все вдала Кан приходить сюди Майже щодня
вона втратила велику частину своєї
родини під час землетрусів
це могила моєї племінниці
їй було 9 місяців тут Мій батько і моя
мати тут один із моїх братів з дітьми і
дружиною
Іноді мені шкода що я не померла з ними
важко так жити далі
а діаман вважається твердиною партією
президента речепа та і передогана
але землетруси могли похитнути довіру до
багаторічного турецького лідера і його
ісламської партії
нещодавно ердуган приїхав вадіа Мани
пообіцяв швидку реконструкцію але в
наметових містечках де зараз доводиться
жити багатьом панує скептицизм
після інших землетрусів теж не все
відбудували
[музика]
тому я не думаю що вони щось зроблять
Вони просто забудуть про нас
кажуть що за рік відбудують наші будинки
як це можливо
Ми навіть не можемо розгребти завали за
один рік а діамант досі одні суцільні
руїни
пердоган обіцяє допомогти тільки для
перемоги на виборах готовий покраситися
люди тут голодні нещасні
Бурак бензет голова опозиційної рнп
вадіманій Він каже що уряд дає багато
обіцянок перед виборами які відбудуться
14 травня але реальні за його словами
інша
після землетрусів минулий місяці а
туалетів питної води досі не вистачає
люди наметах не мають жодних перспектив
це провал держави
ніхто крім уряду не несе за це
відповідальності на виборах буде
політичний землетрус не лише тут але й
по всій країні і це буде непоганий
землетрус а дуже хороший
це мало втішає тих хто вижив але чиї
життя були розбиті на шматки
а й ліндок девірен оплакує втрату своїх
батьків і брата
А вона відчуває себе безпорадною і
самотньою
мені сумно що є більше не зможу
проводити час зі своєю сім'єю
моєму братові мало виповнитися 15 років
Я принесла йому на могилу святковий торт
але він не зміг бути поруч щоб задути
свічки
а й Лін не було в iddi аманів той день
коли стали землетруси коли Вона
повернулась будинку її сім'ї вже не було
за її словами рятувальники прибули лише
за кілька днів
значна частина міста зруйнована багато
будинків були неякісно збудовані
експерти кажуть що уряд не зробив
достатньо щоб бути готовими до
землетрусів до сьогодні ніхто не може
точно сказати скільки людей загинуло
ніхто не визнає помилок
[музика]
ніхто не йде у відставку Ніхто не бере
на себе відповідальність
якби будівлі будувалися сейсмостійкими
якби Влада регулярно їх перевіряла то не
загинуло б стільки людей
Сулейман кілінг багато разів чув цю
критику протягом останніх тижнів він сам
втратив родичів під час землетрусів
але як мер аді амана і представник
правлячої партії пср багато хто каже що
він частково несе відповідальність за
проблеми
можливо були недоліки Але точно не
навмисно
ніхто не повинен спотворювати правду щоб
отримати політичну вигоду тепер ми
повинні подбати про проблеми людей
це наш план і ми будемо продовжувати це
робити так само як ми це робили останні
20-30 років
на кладовищі десавдала кано-лакує свою
сім'ю розмови про майбутні вибори
здаються чимось далеким
багато хто навіть не знає де серед руїн
вони зможуть голосувати
тут усе стає зрозумілим Хто б не переміг
перед ними постане дуже велике завдання
відродити надію
там де зараз панує лише відчай
війна в Україні стала прямою загрозою
для країн що межують із Чорним морем
води стали небезпечним місцем навіть для
пляжників у місті Констанца в Румунії
яка входить до складу Європейського
Союзу морські міни дрейфують у морі
далеко від своїх намічених цілей
вибухові пристрої становлять загрозу не
лише для плавців а й для судноплавства
місцевим рибалкам таким як георги міни
дуже сильно заважають вони ставлять під
загрозою його засоби до існування і він
знає що кожен вихід до моря може стати
для нього останнім
георги Дан джурджіл любить рибалити на
Чорному морі його комерційне судно
Одіссея відчалює з румунського Порту
Констанца
але спочатку війни в сусідній Україні
його увага зосереджена не лише на
скумбрії та мідіях
Віктор так-так
бачив Сьогодні мінус
Фламінго щасливчик
Фламінго так називається Рибальське
судно яке нещодавно знайшло морську міну
георги та його команді потрібно рибалити
щоб заробляти гроші але він каже що
страх перед змінами ускладнює роботу
ми часто ловимо мідії вночі але зараз це
складно не можна виходити в море якщо
туман або якщо Місячне сяйво недостатньо
яскраве
треба залишатися в досі ми боїмося йти
навіщо ризикувати можна загинути
Чорне море завжди було важливим для тих
хто живе на його узбережжі і заробляє
завдяки цьому на життя але воно також
вкрай важливий для тих хто пропливає
через нього до війни в Україні Це був
найважливіший маршрут для експорту зерна
з України
але війна перетворила його на страшенну
небезпечне місце
морські міни тепер плавають по чорному
морю їх відносно дешево виробляти і
важко помічати течії та хвилі можуть їх
переміщати
Ось чому ніщо не може замінити людське
око
кораблі ВМС Румунії як цей займається
відстеження морських мін і знешкодженням
знайдених
ми розпочнемо процедуру знешкодження
міни яку щойно виявили на поверхні води
як завжди діти відповідно до вашої
підготовки
гідрокостюми будьте готові зануритися у
воду і провести знешкодження цієї міни
до війни в Україні ці водолази
спеціалісти займалися знешкодження
морських мін часів Другої світової війни
але зараз вони зіткнулися з новими
мінами
незалежно від того встановлені вони
Росії чи Україною для захисту своїх
портів небезпека однакова
наші місії дуже ризиковані через те з
чим ми маємо справу Ніна сама по собі
становить реальну небезпеку так само як
і вибухові пристрої які ми
використовуємо тому ми повинні підходити
до цього з особливою обережністю
сьогодні рівень ризику нижчий це лише
тренування Що підготувати водолазів до
наступної морської міни з якої вони
зіткнуться це прекрасне румунське
узбережжя у констанції знаходиться
всього в декількох морських милях від
нас
незабаром воно буде заповнене туристами
ті хто вже тут знають про небезпеку
Сподіваюся буде безпечно і я зможу піти
із сім'єю на пляж але запливати дуже
далеко не будемо
Сподіваюся їм вдасться зробити пляж
безпечним дуже сподіваюся
ця Міна містила 30 кілограмів вибухівки
досі в сім'ї не виявлені в Чорному морі
були сконструйовані так щоб вони
спрацювали лише від судна а не від
людини
Незважаючи на це румунський флот
намагається тримати всі морські міни
подалі від берега
із Минулого року вони знайшли 5 одну з
них на березі
це небагато
та єдиної міри що опинилися не в тому
місці не той час достатньо щоб завдати
великої шкоди і руйнувань
ідеться про кораблі та об'єкт
інфраструктури такі як порти наприклад
ризик існує завжди
раніше на судні Георга була команда з
5-ти рибалок
трах перед змінами скоротив їхню
кількість до двох це ускладнює роботу
рибалити складніше набагато складніше
ці міни якщо ти зловиш таку сітку і
підтягнеш і близько до корабля може
вибухнути прямо біля тебе це дуже
небезпечно Але що ми можемо зробити Ми
повинні продовжувати рибалити щоб вижити
георги не знає як довго він зможе
продовжувати свій рибальський бізнес а з
такою кількістю морських Мін у воді
ризик натрапити на них залишатиметься ще
довго навіть якщо війна в Україні
незабаром закінчиться
традиційно улюблене місце проживання
диких кабанів ліс але ці тварини добре
пристосовуються до нових умов і швидко
розмножуються
ці фактори сприяли їхній міграції в
містах
всеїдні тварини почуваються як вдома Її
вдосталі тварини не мають жодних проблем
з її пошуком навіть серед білого дня
кабани знахабніли їхня чисельність різко
зросла
почастішали випадки нападів кабанів на
людей
Карлсон офіційної повноважений Барселони
у боротьбі з дикими кабанами які
відповідає за те щоб тримати тварин
подалі від міста Це нелегка робота
кабани розумні швидко навчилися бути
хитрішими ніж мисливці
це і Зак джанніч майстер кунг-фу він
присвятив своє життя тому щоб ділитися
своєю пристрастю до бойових мистецтв з
дітьми та підлітками і він досяг значних
успіхів
зараз за кавшановують за його
багаторічну працю його буде відзначено у
залі слави бойових мистецтв у США але
його спортивному клубу поблизу
боснійського міста с ребраніца не
вистачає коштів незважаючи на цей заклад
вдалося зробити ім’я своєму клубу далеко
за межами Боснії та Герцеговини
і закджаніч присвятив понад 40 років
свого життя мистецтво конфу
Браво близько 6 років тому він заснував
клуб кунг-фу у серебрянці і відтоді його
репутація тільки зростає
цього року нас запросили представляти
всю боснію і герцеговину на Чемпіонаті
Світу
ми пишалися цим і були сповнені енергії
саме тому показали такі високі
результати три золоті та 4 срібні медалі
і це всього 5А бійцями Це фантастичний
результат
своїх учнів він називає драконами своїх
дітей у нього немає
сьогодні у клубі троє учнів аднела
найздібніша
у Будапешті було чудово величезна
конкуренція Мені 14 і я дуже рада що
поїхала туди Я досягла неабиякого успіху
одна золота і одна срібна медаль 35
країн змагалися в Угорщині загалом Майже
2000 майстрів бойових мистецтв і
незважаючи на свої розміри Боснія ігор
цього вина посіла 9 місце у медальному
заліку для ізика та його учнів перша
битва починається за межами татамі їм
важко платити за оренду клубу але їхнє
завзятість ймовірно стала однією з
причин їхніх високих результатів сам
ізак скромна людина його пенсія
становить всього близько 120 євро на
місяць цього недостатньо щоб прожити
навіть у бідній Боснії тому він також
тримає ціле подвір'я овець та кіс
продам це працює доволі непогано
Я продаю ягнят і молодих кіз ми тільки
вдвох я і моя дружина
Вона хворіє але ми якось зводимо кінці з
кінцями нам багато не треба
і того що є на вистачає
а потім на початку весни прийшла звістка
з далекої Америки
успіхи і Зака як тренера принесла йому
місце у залі слави бойових мистецтв США
це велика честь і визнання його зусиль
Це просто вершина того чого можна
досягти в бойових мистецтвах принаймні
для мене
я не думаю що може бути більше визнання
хіба що Перемога на Чемпіонаті Світу
це було приблизно на тому ж рівні
отримати Золоту медаль але для мене це
важливіше
та як оплатити поїздку до США у клубу
Немає коштів щоб спонсорувати її місто
сребральниця виділяє клубу лише близько
двох тисяч євро на рік Хоча зараз він
налічує понад сотню членів і Зак не хоче
стягувати плату за членство багато
членів клубу не можуть собі цього
дозволити вони ходять на тренування до
місцевої гімназії
ви бачили коли ми приїхали сюди в
туалетах не було води
я міг би скасувати тренування але Ми
продовжуємо
А щодо екіпіровки У нас є чотири
комплекти тренувального спорядження
двоє можуть битися двоє переодягатися
як екіпірування дороге а грошей клубу
немає ми просто викручуємося як можемо
приватні донори час від часу стають
спонсорами особливо для фінансування
поїздок на змагання але ізак здається не
хоче просити гроші на поїздку до США
його друзі та члени клубу збирають гроші
для нього
мало хто тут має роботу і нам важко
зібрати гроші щоб відправити тренера і
Зака до США на церемонію вшанування в
залі слави Але у нас все одно вийде
зібрати гроші тому що ми дуже дуже
пишаємося ним
проводить ще одне тренування вдома
потрібно двоє чоловіків щоб повісити
боксерську грушу для неї
і ось 14-річна дівчина береться за
справу і вибиває з груші у стінутрощі
її навички бойових мистецтв викликають
повагу
хлопців в школі зі мною не зв'язуються
хоча й намагалися і чим це закінчилося
не дуже добре для них
і якщо вона продовжить наполегливо
тренуватися навряд чи добре буде і її
майбутнім суперникам у цьому із
упевнений
Адже для нього важливіше за власне
визнання майбутнє його завзятих драконів
а вони вже сотні років частина
паризького міського пейзажу
бокіймістичні набережній на річці
сенаторці продаються антикварні книги на
набережній навіть отримали статус
спадщини Юнеско туристи та місцеві
жителі приходять до яток У пошуках
скарбів та вигідних пропозицій
незважаючи на чарівність ностальгію бути
букіністом це справа серця а не
заробіток це професія яка потребує
досвіду пристрасті і трохи везіння
як це надихає а на цьому тижні це все
дякуємо за перегляди до зустрічі у
наступному випуску програми У фокусі
Європа
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]